انتشر مقطع فيديو كناري في الهشم غريب
وغير مالوف لاسد ياكل الحشائش داخل حظيره
للحيوانات بالخرطوم وحسد المقطع تفاعل
اللافتا بمواقع التواصل اجتماعي في
السودان بدورها اوضحت حديقه السودان
بالحياه البيئيه ان المشهد يبدو غريبا
وغير طبيعيه لكن الحقيقه ان الاسود تاكل
الاعشاب والحشائش من وقت لاخر
[موسيقى]
اثار جمال شلال وسلاميه في السعوديه
الدهشه رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مؤخرا بعد تساقط الامطار ووثق المصور
السعودي رائد العوفي هذا المشهد الخلاف
والساحر في المدينه المنوره
في ظاهره طبيعيه نادره لم تحدث منذ سنوات
وتداول رواد مواقع تواصل الاجتماعي
فيديوهات بولايه بشار الواقعه جنوبي غرب
الجزائر وهي تكتسب اللون الابيض بعد تساقط
الثلوج عليها وتقى عدد من الجزائريين
دهشتهم من اختفاء الملامح الطابع الصحراوي
بسبب الثلوج
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء